(adventurous music)
- I've been called a rock star botanist,
because I do roping,
cliff climbing, hiking
miles and miles and miles, but
that was where the plants were.
There is this huge extinction crisis
going on in Hawaii, and my caring
about the plants is
really what is driving me.
(adventurous music)
(helicopter whirring)
Everything OK?
Well my name is Steve
Perlman, and I do work
for the plant extinction
prevention program in Hawaii.
Our program focuses on the plants
that are extremely rare in Hawaii,
that have less than 50
individuals left in the wild.
(gentle music)
This is a crater of Mount Wai'ale'ale,
the rainiest spot on earth, and then
in this special spot, there
are several species of plants
that are only known from
this area and nowhere else.
(lighthearted music)
What we'll do, is try
to make seed collections
of these really rare species
that are going extinct.
This is the cyanea asarifolia,
they're extremely rare.
I'm bagging the immature fruit right here,
so that we can come back
and get seeds later.
Field botanists these
days are really having
to push the limits to get
to a lot of our plants.
The rocks are slippery,
it's sometimes muddy,
and very steep, there are no trails,
people rarely come back here.
This is the lysimachia iniki, nowhere else
in the world does this thing grow.
About 40 plants or so
are known, and that's it.
And we only can get it when it washes down
the cliffs in heavy rains and storms.
(ambient music)
There is a wonderful feeling, to go into
these remote areas and then
successfully locate plants.
This plant is beautiful and unique,
they've evolved in the Hawaiian islands.
(relaxed music)
You're out there with a plant that has
only one or two of the
plants left in the wild,
you're really, really feeling the emotion
of what that's like, you
go and visit those plants
many times, it's often
becomes like your family.
It has been a really strenuous career,
I'm turning 70 years old next month,
and I still love the work that I do.
I think I'd probably be bored just hanging
around the house, and I don't like
to watch much TV or things like that,
so I wanna keep doing
this work and not retire.
(lighthearted music)